Y
ARE DOING AND WE ARE GOING TO
TRY TO LEARN.
TO LEARN MORE TONIGHT WE ARE
JOINED BY STEPHEN MILLER, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR WHOSE DEEP
KNOWLEDGE OF IMMIGRATION LAW AND
OF THIS.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: IT IS NOW BEYOND
DISPUTE THAT THE BIDEN A
ADMINISTRATION IS MOVING VERY
LARGE NUMBERS OF FOREIGN
NATIONALS WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY
INTO THE INTERIOR OF THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT THE CONSENT OF THE NAVAL
NEIGHBORHOODS INTO WHICH THEY
ARE SETTLING THEM.
IS THAT LEGAL?
>> NO, IT IS ABSOLUTELY NOT
LEGAL.
IT VIOLATES A WIDE SERIES OF
IMMIGRATION LAWS THAT DELINEATE
IN GREAT DEPTH THE PRECISE RULES
AND CONDITIONS FOR HOW YOU CAN
ENTER THE COUNTRY AND HOW YOU
CANNOT ENTER THE COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHY, IN FACT, MY
ORGANIZATION, AMERICA FIRST
LEGAL, JUST ARGUED ALONGSIDE
TEXAS IN FEDERAL COURT THAT
THESE POLICIES MUST BE ENJOINED,
BUT WHAT I WANT TO GET ACROSS TO
YOUR AUDIENCE TO REALLY ADVANCE
THE STORY IS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT IS HAPPENING NOW IS
UNPRECEDENTED.
AND THE WHOLE CONVERSATION ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY UP TO THIS POINT
IN TIME HAS BEEN WRONG.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT IS UNABLE TO
PROTECT THE BORDER.
THIS IS ABOUT AN ADMINISTRATION
THAT IN A VERY PURPOSEFUL,
PLANNED, DELIBERATE, PAINSTAKING
FASHION HAS TURNED OUR BORDER
PATROL AND ICE AGENCIES INTO
RESETTLEMENT AGENCIES.
THAT IS THE WORD THAT EVERYONE
NEEDS TO KNOW AND REPEAT.
THIS IS A PLANNED RESETTLEMENT.
THE LARGEST OF ITS KIND, I WOULD
SUGGEST PERHAPS IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD.
IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
ILLEGAL BORDER CROSSERS BEING
RESETTLED INTO THE INTERIOR OF
OUR COUNTRY IN VIOLATION OF LAW.
>> Tucker: SO THERE'S VERY
LITTLE -- I MEAN, YOU HAVE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS USING THE
LAW TO TRY AND STOP THIS.
IT'S HAPPENING IN REAL TIME,
IT'S BEEN HAPPENING FOR SIX
MONTH WITHOUT THE KNOWLEDGE OF
THE 320 MILLION AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHOSE COUNTRY THIS IS,
BUT THERE IS SOMEONE WHO CAN
STOP IT, THAT'S GREG ABBOTT, THE
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS AND OF COURSE
IT'S HIS BORDER OVER WHICH A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE ARE COMING.
WHY WOULDN'T HE SHUT THE BORDER
TONIGHT WITH MEXICO AND STOP
THIS?
>> WELL, I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE CONSTITUTIONAL
REMEDY IS ARTICLE FOUR,
SECTION 4, WHICH SAYS THAT THE
GOVERNMENT CLEARLY HAS THE
OBLIGATION TO PROTECT ANY STATE
IN THIS COUNTRY AGAINST INVASION
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IT DOES NOT SAY THAT THAT HAS TO
BE IN THE FORM OF A NATION STATE
ACTOR.
IN OTHER WORDS, THE CONSTITUTION
DOESN'T SAY IT HAS TO BE A
STATE-LED INVASION.
IT'S ANY LARGE-SCALE, UNWELCOME,
UNINVITED ENTRY INTO A COUNTRY.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THE
CONSTITUTIONAL PREDICATE FOR
EXACTLY WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING.
I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST IT WOULD
PROVIDE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
PREDICATE FOR THE SUPREME COURT,
IF THEY HAD THE MORAL COURAGE,
TO STRIKE DOWN THIS ENTIRE
SCHEME, WHICH IS A BLATANT
VIOLATION OF OUR ENTIRE
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLICAN FORM
OF GOVERNMENT.
LET'S BE VERY CLEAR.
WHEN JOE BIDEN PUT HIS HAND ON
THE BIBLE AND SWORE AN OATH TO
TAKE CARE OF THE LAWS WE
FAITHFULLY EXECUTED, TO UPHOLD,
PROTECT, AND DEFEND THE
CONSTITUTION, TO ENSURE A
REPUBLICAN FORM OF GOVERNMENT TO
EVERY STATE, HE HAS VIOLATED
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
COMMITMENTS.
I WILL ALSO ADD THIS: IF THAT'S
NOT AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE, I
CAN'T IMAGINE WHAT WOULD BE.
>> Tucker: NO, THAT'S RIGHT.
AND YOU KNOW THAT THIS IS CORE
TO THEIR GOVERNING PLANS,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU MENTION IT,
THEY GO CRAZY, AND THEY CALL YOU
THE WORST KIND OF SLURS WHEN IN
FACT I DON'T THINK THERE IS A
LARGE GROUP OF PEOPLE ANYWHERE
IN THIS COUNTRY OF ANY COLOR, OF
ANY POLITICAL AFFILIATION, WHO
IS IN FAVOR OF THIS.
I MEAN, IF PEOPLE WERE IN FAVOR
OF THIS, WHY ISN'T THERE A BILL
IN THE U.S. CONGRESS JUST TO
ADMIT A MILLION NEW FOREIGN
NATIONALS EVERY SIX MONTHS?
>> EXACTLY.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS THEY ARE
DOUBLING, TRIPLING -- WHATEVER
THE NUMBER IS AT THE END OF THE
AIR, WHO KNOWS, IT KEEPS GOING
HIGHER AND HIGHER AND HIGHER,
THERE'S NO CEILING THAT'S BEEN
HIT YET, THE NUMBER OF MIGRANTS
BEING ADMITTED INTO OUR COUNTRY
EVERY SINGLE YEAR ABOVE THE
ALREADY SKY-HIGH LEVELS
AUTHORIZED IN FEDERAL LAW.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT, NOBODY IS
GOING UP PUBLICLY, NOT
SENATOR MANCHIN, NOT
SENATOR MARK KELLY, NOT EVEN
NANCY PELOSI OR CHUCK SCHUMER
SAYING AMERICA, HERE'S WHY WE
THINK WE NEED MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS MORE
MIGRANTS EVERY SINGLE YEAR THEN
WE ARTY HAVE.
AND BY THE WAY, WE ALSO WOULD
LIKE THEM NOT TO HAVE HEALTH
INSURANCE, WOULD LIKE THEM NOT
TO HAVE COLLEGE EDUCATION AND
WOULD LIKE THEM TO RELY ON LARGE
AMOUNTS OF FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS, INCLUDING FREE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
NOBODY IS MAKING THAT ARGUMENT
BECAUSE NOBODY COULD MAKE THAT
ARGUMENT, BECAUSE THERE ISN'T
ANY PRINCIPLED ARGUMENT FOR IT
AND THEN NEVER COULD BE.
ENTER YOUR POINT ABOUT RACE,
HISPANIC-AMERICANS, BLACK
AMERICANS, ASIAN-AMERICAN, WHITE
AMERICANS, EVERY CATEGORY OF
AMERICAN -- AND BY THE WAY,
EVERY PERSON IN EVERY COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD THAT HAS EVER LIVED
ONCE A SECURE BORDER AND A
CONTROLLED IMMIGRATION POLICY,
PERIOD.
>> Tucker: MUST BE A WHITE
ASSIST!
IT'S ABOUT CONSENT.
IF WE WANT -- LET'S DO IT
DEMOCRATICALLY.
THEY ARE DOING IN THE MANNER OF
A AUTHORITARIAN GOVERNMENT, THEY
ARE JUST DOING IT AND HURTI